[Music]
and there's new takeover news over the
world dun dun dun yeah literally
submitted by the snap oh snap
Oh assuming is a nose I don't feel so
good mr. right
good boy announces is full lineup or
it's November 12th launch day what is it
what is it what is it yeah this year
November last year
WAPA ng price of $6.99 a month eight
bucks I think seven 9s six nine they're
gonna monopolize everyone out of
business that's how you started that's
how you get fi you take controllers get
all the head of coke is free every time
Liz let me tell you like I had scrolled
before the cameras rolled I was
scrolling for like five minutes and you
still hasn't hit the bottom innit I need
to brush up on this real quick it was
like nah [ __ ] it there's got to be at
least 100 to 200 titles that are
launching with alone and there's new
titles would mix with there's movies
from the 1940s a lot of NJ scavengers
like Song of the South there they're
coming hard there's like us there's like
a Kim Possible live-action movie at or
like that where they're creating it they
already made it it was apparently really
bad into launching November 12
oh so it's launching with the release
Disney plus there's other stuff that's
getting really thick mandalorian
Mandalorians gonna be on launch day so
that's no [ __ ] way it's the series
URI
that's the series yeah so I thought it
was a movie for the series yeah and
every every I don't know if you guys
grew up with a Disney Channel movies a
little bit wider range a drink or brink
keep up inside I made my fantasy
football team every year pup n suds yeah
that's a great mood read Disney Channel
movie you could think of launching this
is launching with it
and every Disney Channel like original
show you could think of damn there's a
Lizzie McGuire reboot oh [ __ ]
I think they're already rebooting a
raven like that's all Raven reboots
Raven Symone I think she's like an older
character my gosh yeah like beef with
Disney yeah I thought like like publicly
like put it out there like they didn't
want to work there rebooting in High
School Musical as a series so it is
brand-new cast
that's not watching usually you find
newer younger Vanessa Hudgens no that's
pedo pad damn they're not releasing new
films or new reboots they're releasing
nostalgia right now yeah Oh balls I mean
a new Jeff Goldblum show is coming out
the same thing the fly for the team for
TV the flag for TV G bring that up
because I just watched a video I'd say
on the fly and I remember how gross it
Disney also National Geographic they're
coming out with a Gordon Ramsay show
alright it's like Uncharted yeah we're
Hugh it's like survivor man mixed
[ __ ] or no sorry it's like Anthony
Bourdain's thing right it's like similar
kind of concept Wow
of course all the Marvel movies for
price of something under $10 you watch
it wherever and whenever
how many guys member have multiple
accounts yeah dad I don't know can you
pull like on Netflix and have one person
and then everyone else logs in I feel
like the industry's industry standard
nowadays is that you got to pay like two
three bucks more and then you gotta buy
two more devices or whatever they limit
to you buy devices how many devices
allow you to it doesn't it doesn't say
come I feel like two is fair I think
it's gonna be - usually I feel like it -
it's like I can live with - as long as
they give me a quick logout option so I
log out everybody else when I log reckon
around yeah there's gonna be a new
Freaky Friday here's here's what's gonna
happen
they're releasing it at $6.99 with ads
are they they could do that they coming
up material does that [ __ ] all I do
guessing that's gonna be a gimmick and
then they're gonna release like Oh
$12.99 $12.99 premium no ass yeah
because that's what Hulu does Hulu will
give you their like base plan for like
what $10 $8 a month and then they give
ad murmur when tyloo is free I love the
way it was free and then it played out
it's yeah yeah cuz I was like man if I'm
paying for it money let me ask you guys
this do you think this will be like the
streaming service to end all streaming
services there'll be a strong contender
I don't know that it'll end everything
else cuz I think Netflix has a really
has gotten a nice foothold in with a lot
of their original content and stuff and
I feel like they're kind of studio level
grade stuff for they're like starting to
punch like above their weight class it's
in some areas like they're proven that
they can do it so I don't know that
it'll end Netflix but it'll definitely
give them a run for the money because of
how many things Disney is pulling out of
Netflix - I think it'll pump the brakes
on all other streaming sites in terms of
like expansion expansion growth yeah I
think everyone else will have to then
realize what's going on and they'll have
to step up their game yeah what would
that entail oh like stepping up your
game it's like if you don't have more
money to throw at the problem that is it
sort of virtual reality did have some
sort of spin or twist on it they're
gonna connect all they're like headsets
it's gonna become like a [ __ ] Wow
Netflix now include pornhub amazing I
remember they owned Fox - so all the
cartoons you go Simpsons - Nami Disney
oh no - Douglas Cartoon Network car -
yeah huge thing a couple months ago all
of Fox's assets yeah including things so
yes x-men Simpsons Fantastic Four yeah
and so they're gonna try to bring those
characters into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as well but apparently I read
that they're bringing the x-men cartoon
to Disney Plus yeah they're out the 90s
all the nineties cartoons
gargoyles even regards with Street
sharks owned by Disney
Street Church beetleborgs oh I love that
[ __ ] dude battery ya saben
is it still saving yeah it was fun oh I
think I think Saban is different there
are their own production I was just
going as far back as I can remember in
generally it's not a launching day one
it says command F butyl boards was like
I think the same company as Power
Rangers and then they go yeah it was but
I don't think that's a Disney privately
I I was just curious that was tasting I
don't remember I was I didn't pay
attention I love that show deed
I love the suits at there I just you
just took me back with the whole street
sharks and I was just like oh my god
beetle what the weirdest thing is I
never actually watched street sharks
it's not commercials for my parents
never let me watch it so I saw violent I
had one VHS that I would always watch
over and over and I never actually
watched the show yeah there's a lot of
shows like that what's with Chinese on
Fox or that one's DC so there's this
seal the deal are you guys gonna this
holiday season I kinda just want a
DeLorean like that's my biggest thing so
you could pay seven dollars to watch
mammal yeah for the one like I don't
know if I can keep it but like I think I
definitely watch it for they're hoping
to suck you in yeah
oh but they do they're scrubs here's
whate has has all the other content from
Disney been pulled already from other
streaming sites starting to close it's
starting to so there's they've been
pulling pulling out slowly
they pull out but I'm also just curious
if it's just gonna like wipe so much
clean off of like other streaming sites
that it's gonna force people to purchase
force people to purchase the Disney Plus
stuff yeah anything about it's so
family-friendly like all the families
that purchase Netflix for their kids are
obviously gonna be like do it have a
price I get even more kid stuff I don't
have to do like like YouTube kids
anymore either cuz I know like a lot of
parents use YouTube to entertain their
kids that way boom just throwing Disney
Plus and they know that it's always
gonna be safe content Co Ghibli films on
there cuz I know that for a while
doesn't he kind of have like
sort of Disney Dena does not own the
distribution rights to studio gippy G
kids owns the North American
distribution rights how do you feel
about like Disney acquiring all of this
though I even borrow just take it over
take it over the world man I mean the
happiest place on the world trying to
make it the happiest place of the world
I feel like Disneyland is our equivalent
to Samsung in Korea because Sam sounds
like a huge conglomerate oh yeah yeah
like they own everything there I think
there are other bigger scarier companies
in America though actually other than
Disney you're talking about like like
Monsanto Monsanto like Monsanto
agriculture like they'll only tell them
a ton of food there's that whole poison
Monsanto scary like product that
Monsanto was going through but they
literally just swept it on there yeah
like there's a lot of scary scary big
industrial companies that you don't [ __ ]
with America and I think those are the
big scary ones that say I would rank
rank lummix dancing as far as media goes
yeah I think Disney is like one of the
largest scariest globally yeah
especially it's scary I think it's scary
but at the same time like I'm just going
to do look at the Irish dog I feel so
good but then the same time my adult -
like this monopoly is I'm caving into
this man I'm definitely gonna cave like
I'm going to cave so we get a JK
accountant just pass her up I know I
wanna I want to know what like not like
the loopholes within it but like I want
to know how they're gonna like present
it to people like what what's that gonna
be their capabilities with like one
membership sign up adding all the extra
accounts or like how many devices can be
viewed at once kind of thing like I'm
just basing this all up Netflix right
now and I don't know any other way if
they're just gonna do unlimited
unlimited a to start with just
monopolize the whole system to just give
out free crack cocaine everybody take as
much as you want
oh you like then just bump up the price
after that and then everyone was hurt
that's like some Pinocchio [ __ ] oh yeah
okay was it like a museum park and they
all turn into donkeys after they all got
drunk what what what is it
alley cats strike what's that wait wait
this the bowling movie is that the one
where finger up yeah when he's a
basketball player meets a bowling though
this basketball player who's cool and
thinks he's the best that he's best at
every sport except for bullying but then
that he wants to dominate bowling cuz
this guy is like really good at it but
this guy's a loser and he's just like
you're playing a loser sport and then
they learn and it only became cool so
the basketball guy of course had to be
like I got it I gotta be cool on top of
this game so it's a constant does a
bowler learn basketball no it's not one
of those bullied and stuff
yeah they become friends yeah smart
house on that little house on the way
yeah that's not the same owning
everything
ouch how should you feel you know as a
as a more adult that's like a consumer
now more of consumer like do you let
this conglomerate continue its yes I for
one love Disney Plus yeah I would love
to work with Disney Disney brand deal I
love Disney Disney can take over the
entire world
I'll do the entire brand deal Disney did
a great job
I guess create creating and building my
childhood I'm about to create and build
your adulthood do it had like great
shows great cartoons
do that [ __ ] made me love snowboarding
so much more than what I already doing
right now it's a snowboarder that
becomes a surfer a surfer that moves to
Vermont
oh and he's like wow no beaches here
that guy's dad is soul Ryan he's
Japanese he's a Japanese out there yeah
exactly
you might know that accurate there's
beef between the skiers and the
snowboarders oh go ahead it has that old
guy carry here yogi
Segawa dude he's the guy from Mortal
Kombat your soul is mine right sounds
like all Japanese names is Boy Meets
World a part of that yes boy me sir they
actually Boise for the whole series we
should be on a plan together I'm [ __ ]
I love he's related to ride somehow so
though now that we don't worry all the
same here oh yeah game over guys
[Music]